nous racontons la partie secrète de la
bataille la partie secrète de la vie des bigorneaux
c'est une histoire incroyable mais je me sentais juste comme
quelque chose que je n'avais pas vu tout tourne autour de
cette figure emblématique mais à travers ce
Cassini est un chasseur de vampires c'est comme un
Batman du 19ème siècle  parce qu'il était
ordinaire et extraordinaire en même
temps, il est une image tellement emblématique
et il y a quelque chose de très fort dans
cette image, c'est juste très puissant quand
il comprend la façon dont le monde est vraiment,
il est motivé par la vengeance en
battant le noir,
c'est incroyablement excitant
Lee Dark, il répond sera vraiment
surpris de ce que nous leur lançons cette grande
première fois que le public verra leur
président se battre pour protéger les
vampires d'Abraham Lincoln Timur wow c'est le
genre de film que je
vous